if you want someone to treat you
differently you have to first address it
as soon as possible when they do
something against it because you want to
keep the latency between when they do
something you don't like and when you
tell them about it as short as you can
so that you can actually train the
behavior even something as simple as
like someone says hey get over here I
mean if I'm sitting on the couch and
someone says hey get over here I going
say don't ever talk to me like that I'm
not your dog be like whoa I mean dude no
need to have a short fuse I was like I
don't have that either I just don't want
you to talk to me that way and then it's
weird and silent and awkward and then
they need to make a decision what